I am gonna hold your fucking hand through starting a business
using some skill that you probably already have
and are a fucking expert at.
Because you're a stay at home mom and all you do is like
shit that you could charge people for and charge a lot of money
and you can do it to fit your schedule and all that shit.
So I'm about to get to work to continue working on all the.
The fucking course material.
I'm not. This is not something that I bought from somebody
and I'm just selling it to you.
I'm like literally making this shit,
not just by myself. My friend who actually owns a business,
she has helped people earn millions of dollars in revenue
by running their ads. So it was the two of us together.
We're both single moms, we both had four kids.
We just had so much in common
and it felt nice to do it together,
help lighten the load and help expand that what we can offer.
So because it's live, it's not, um,
some made up shit like every fucking week on Thursday.
If you're able to attend it live,
we're gonna be live
and answering your questions and helping you with that days like
fucking thing, helping you switch gears into the next like
set of shit that you're gonna do.
Because both of us have started a business,
both of us have earned some money,
and we both understand what It is to be a stay at home mom and be like,
oh my god, I feel so lost in life,
what can I do? And you just feel like such a haze or.
Or you feel the feeling of like, okay,
but I could do so many things.
I could bake cakes, I could clean houses.
I could fucking organize. I could this.
I don't know. Like,
we fucking got you.
I'm not. I'm not fucking being scary
because I'm not a scary fucking person.
I'm not gonna. This is my shit and I fucking believe in it.
So if you wanna sign up, the link is right here. Okay?